in this video you're going to learn how
to solve linear equations involving one
variable and we're going to talk about
one-step equations two-step equations
and multi-step equations as well as
variables on the left side and the right
side of the equation now when you're
solving linear equations it's helpful to
think of these three easy steps and I'll
talk about it as we work through these
problems
but the first step is you want to
simplify the left and right sides of the
equation first as much as you can then
you want to get the variables and the
numbers on opposite sides of that equal
sign and the last step is you always
want to solve for just one of the
variable so go ahead and pause the video
if you want to try some of these on your
own we'll go through them together the
first one we have X minus 3 equals 10
now what some students like to do you
know when I'm tutoring students
sometimes they'll mention things that
their teachers say to me such as you
know their teacher reference this says
the great wall of math meaning you know
you've got the left side of this
equation okay on this side of the line
and the right side of the equation so
you can kind of think of that as the two
sides but what you want to do is you
want to see first can you simplify this
left side at all well we can't we really
can't can combine a number and a
variable together over here we just have
a number so all we can really do here at
this point is go to step number two we
want to say are the variables and the
numbers on opposite sides well you can
see the variables here on the left but
we still have this number here and we
have a number here so we want to get
these numbers together on one side so
what I'm going to do to get rid of the
three here is do the opposite operation
so remember subtraction in addition or
opposites multiplication and division or
opposites etc so instead of subtracting
three what I'm going to do is I'm going
to add three whatever you do to the left
you want to do to the right to keep it
balanced okay
so now I like to draw a line I like to
keep everything lined up 10 plus 3 is 13
negative 3 plus 3 that cancels Esch is 0
and you can see we get x equals 13 now
if you want to check your work the nice
thing about algebra is you can take that
number put it back into the original
equation so I could say 13 minus 3 yes
that's 10 now these ones are kind of
simple you probably guess the answer
just by looking at it but as we get into
the
step and the multi step and the
variables on both sides it gets a little
bit more challenging so let's go through
the steps for number two now for y
divided by five equals negative 4 what
would you do for this one well if you're
following the steps first you would
simplify the right side and the left
side but there's really nothing that we
can simplify then we want to get the
variables and numbers on opposite sides
well you can see to get this Y by itself
we're going to have to get rid of this 5
here and the opposite of dividing by 5
is 2 multiplied by 5 so I'm going to
multiply the left side by 5 I'm going to
multiply the right side by 5 5 divided
by 5 is 1 1 times anything is itself so
you can see we're getting just Y by
itself and we get negative 20 so that
was kind of a simple one let's go to
number 3 this one we've got 11 plus a
equals negative 8 we want to get of
course the variable by itself we have to
get rid of this 11 to get that variable
by itself so I'm going to do the
opposite of positive 11 say this is a
positive 11 which is kind of like adding
11 we want to do the opposite we want to
subtract 11 whatever we do to the left
we want to do to the right to keep it
balanced now you can see these cancel
out and we get a equals negative 8 minus
11 which is negative 19 now if you want
to check your work you just go ahead and
put it back in 11 plus negative 19
equals negative 8 and you can verify you
got it right number 4 we've got negative
56 equals negative 8c well here what we
can do is we want to get this C by
itself so instead of multiplying by
negative 8 let's go ahead and divide
both sides by negative 8 you can see
these cancel and we have C by itself
negative 56 divided by negative 8 is
positive 7 because the two negatives
will give you a positive and that's your
final answer now it doesn't matter
whether the variable ends up on the
right or the left but the main thing is
you want to solve for just one of that
variable and you got it okay now to step
equations let's look at three examples
here we're going to follow these steps
again simplify the left and right sides
so for number five if I look at this
left side of this equation I really
can't combine the e and there's no
because they're unlike terms one's a
variable one's a number so then we go to
step number two we want to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
opposite side so here I've got 16 on the
right I've got this negative 2 here on
the left I want to move this to the
other side and the way you do that is by
doing the opposite instead of
subtracting 2 let's add 2 of course
whatever do to left we want to do to the
right to keep it balanced right so this
comes out to 18 negative 2 plus 2 is 0 I
don't usually write the 0 and then we've
got 6e we're just bringing that down
okay now we are on to step number 3 we
want to solve for one of the variable
we've got 6e here we just want to solve
for 1ee
because these are next to each other
that means they're multiplied together
so what's the opposite of multiplying by
6 dividing by 6 whatever you do to the
left you want to do to the right these
cancel or you can think of 6 divided by
6 says 1e or you can just write e equals
18 divided by 6 which is 3 again if
you're not sure if you're doing it right
you can always take that number put it
back into the original problem 3 times 6
is 18 minus - yes that's 16 so we know
we got it right see if you can do number
6 now we've got negative 15 equals D
divided by 3 minus 12 so let's follow
the step step number one we would try to
simplify the right side okay but we
really can't combine this because we
have a variable in a number and we try
to simplify what's over here on the left
side this is just a number there's
really nothing to simplify these come
into play a little bit more some of
these steps as we get into the
multi-step equations number two though
we want to get the variables on one side
the numbers on the opposite side now
students often say to me Mario how do
you know what side to get everything on
and there's really no right answer you
just want to make sure that you're
separating and you're getting variables
on one side numbers on the other I try
to make it easy on myself though in the
sense that see how the variables already
here on the right but there's no
variables here on the left right so the
variables are already here on the right
let's just leave them on the right and
get the numbers on the left okay this
way it'll be on opposite side so we try
to make it simple but you can't really
make a mistake as long as you do the
same thing to both sides so instead of
subtracting 12 let's add 12 to both
sides you can see these cancel that's 0
you don't have to write 0 bring the d
/ three down and negative 15 plus 12 is
negative three now we're just trying to
solve for one of the variable we just
want D by itself so what's the opposite
of dividing by three multiplying by
three you can see those cancel and if we
do that to the right we want to multiply
the left by three so that comes out to
negative nine and you've got it okay
let's move on to number seven see if you
can do this one here we've got the
variables on the left okay and we've got
numbers over here on the left and the
right so we really want to get the
variables on one side and the numbers on
the other side so let's see if we can
move this negative four to the other
side now you can't just move it all
right you have to kind of get rid of it
and the way to get rid of something is
by doing the opposite so I'm going to
add four to the left I'm going to add
four to the right these are opposites
they cancel and twenty six plus four is
30 now we're down to that last step
solving for just one of the variable
instead of multiplying by negative five
we do the opposite we divide by negative
five
those cancel because anything divided by
itself is one and we get y equals
negative six and you've got it okay now
let's talk about how to handle when you
have variables on both sides of the
equation what do we do in that case well
again we always go back to these three
easy steps we say can we simplify what's
here on the right side can we simplify
what's here on the left side we really
can't combine variables and numbers
together they're unlike terms same thing
here we can't come by in variables and
numbers they're unlike terms we have to
make a decision though and it doesn't
make too much of a difference whether
you get the variables on the left or the
right you just want to make sure that
the variables and the numbers are in
opposite sides so let's just go ahead
and make a decision here how about I get
the variables on the right okay so if I
want the variables okay the letter here
X on the right that means that I have to
get rid of it on the left how do you get
rid of something you do the opposite now
when you look at this 3x is it positive
or negative well if you look to the left
there's nothing there so you can think
of that as a plus sign or a positive
sign that's plus 3x we want to do the
opposite we want to subtract 3x of
course remember whatever you do to the
left you want to do to the right to keep
it balanced so this comes out to 2x plus
9
equals negative seven now you can see
we've made a decision we're gonna get
the variables on the right so that means
we want to get the numbers on the left
so how do I get the numbers on the Left
I have to get rid of them on the right
how do you get rid of something you do
the opposite so that these cancel out we
just get 2x equals negative 16 now we're
down to that last step we want to solve
for one of the variable instead of two
actually just want one X what's the
opposite of multiplying by two dividing
both sides by two and then you can see
we've got a negative 16 divided by two
which is negative 8 equals x and you got
it if you want to check your work you
can take negative 8 put it into X here
put it index here make sure that the
left side on the right side are equal
let's go down to number 9 see if you can
do this one on your own negative 7y plus
4 equals y minus 24 this one I'm going
to get the variables on the left so if I
want to get the variables on the Left I
have to get rid of them on the right how
do I get rid of something I do the
opposite so this is a positive Y here so
that's like plus y I'm going to subtract
Y you want to make sure you do it to
both sides to keep it balanced bring
down the 4 and then we've got these
cancel and we get negative 20 so we made
a decision to get the variables on the
left so that means we're gonna get the
numbers on the opposite side on the
right so in order to get the numbers on
the right I have to get rid of them on
the left by doing the opposite instead
of adding 4 let's subtract 4 and now
this comes out to negative 24 equals
negative 8y the last step is just to
solve for one of the variable instead of
multiplying by negative 8 let's divide
both sides by negative 8 and you can see
that those are gonna cancel and we get y
equals positive 3 and you got it
okay let's try one more of these
variables on both sides before we get to
the multi-step equations here what do
you think we should do should we get the
variables on the left or we should get
them on the right now some students you
know they'll say Mario you know I don't
like negative numbers so much so let me
see if maybe I can get the variables on
the right this way I'll have a positive
variable instead of like having a
negative amount of the
so you can do that if that's more
comfortable for you so what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to add six a to both sides
those cancel and to a plus six a is 8 a
ok see how that's positive but because
we got the variable on the right we want
to get the numbers on the left now
whenever you move something from one
side to the other the sign changes to
the opposite like see this positive 21
if I move it over here it's gonna be
like subtracting 21 so you'd be like a
negative 21 or if I took this negative
and I moved over here would be like plus
11 so you just want to make sure you
don't just move the number you have to
realize that it's going to be the
opposite because to get rid of 21
instead of adding 21 we're subtracting
21 see and then this comes out to
negative 32 equals a a we just want to
solve for 1a so instead of multiplying
by 8 let's divide both sides by 8 and
that comes out to negative 4 and again
you can check it by putting it back in
to make sure the left side the right
sides match okay now let's tackle some
multi-step equations so here's where the
three easy steps will really come in
handy let's start with step number one
we want to simplify the left side of the
equation okay to the left of the equal
sign we want to try to simplify the
right side of the equal sign as much as
you can so here you can see what I have
is 2 times the quantity X minus 3 I'm
going to distribute that 2 into the
parenthesis that's going to give us 2x
minus 6 okay because I'm multiplying
both by 2 minus 4 equals 5x plus 8 okay
now I can also combine negative 6 and
negative 4 to negative 10 so now I've
combined the left side as much as I can
or simplify the right side as much as I
can now we're on to step number 2 we
want to get the variables and the
numbers on opposite sides so here what
I'm going to do I generally like to get
the variables on the left and the
numbers on the right I always just do it
the same way each time so if I want to
get the variables on the left that means
I have to get rid of them on the right
so I'm going to do the opposite I'm
going to subtract 5x these are going to
cancel out this gives us 8 2x minus 5x
is negative 3x we just bring that
negative 10 down it's like you're adding
these two lines together so now we've
got
variables on the left one of the numbers
on the right instead of subtracting 10
let's add 10 that way we get rid of the
numbers on the left and we have negative
3x equals 18 the last step now is to
solve for one of the variable set a
multiplying by negative 3 let's divide
by negative 3 and that gives us x equals
negative 6 and you've got it now again
if you want to check you put it back in
make sure the left side and the right
sides match if you're enjoying the way
that I teach and you want more help
learning algebra 1 or algebra 2 or you
know any other type of math I'll put a
link in the description to some of my
video courses for sale you can check
those out see if it's a good fit for you
otherwise let's do this last multi-step
problem here and see if you can do this
one on your own
what we're going to do here is follow
the three steps we're going to simplify
the left side as much as we can and the
right side as much as we can so here
we've got a little bit of work ahead of
us we've got negative 4y and positive 3y
that combines to negative 1y or you
could just say negative Y we've got the
positive 5 and the negative 7 which adds
up to negative 2 and then here we can
distribute the 2 into the parentheses
that's 2y minus 2 minus 9 we can combine
the negative 2 and the negative 9 to
negative 11 and let's bring down
negative y minus 2 okay so now we
simplify the left side as much as we can
the right side as much as you can we
want to get the variables on one side
numbers on the other like I said in the
last problem I generally just like to
get the variables on the left and the
numbers on the right so to get the
variables on the Left I have to get rid
of them on the right what's the opposite
of adding 2y see this is like plus 2y we
want to do the opposite subtract 2y okay
so that gives us negative 3y minus 2
these cancel equals negative 11 I got
the variables on the left I want to get
the numbers on the right which means I
have to get rid of them on the left so
we want to do the opposite we're going
to add 2 now we're down to negative 3y
negative 3y equals negative 9 instead of
multiplying by negative 3 we're going to
divide both sides by negative 3 and you
can see that comes out to
equals positive three and you got it if
you want to see more multi-step
equations follow me over to that video
right there and we'll dive into some
more problems